hey what's going on everybody super
excited for you guys to watch the jump
cut special
this is just a bunch of riffs and a
couple of my old favorite stories
grouped together from a weekend i did it
one of my favorite clubs in the country
comedy works in denver
i hope you enjoy jump cut special and
remember tune in
for a new live hour of comedy
march 4th streaming at 8 o'clock central
go to comedianjoshwolf.com
for tickets to watch the news special
father time but in the meantime
enjoy the jump cut special y'all later
put your hands together everyone for
josh wolfe
[Applause]
okay it's it's uh what's going on
saturday late show [ __ ] yeah all right
first of all thank you guys for coming
down
and uh man uh
how many people tell you that you look
like guy fieri
fiat everybody
yeah so i would shave the goatee then uh
no
i say it every time i come to denver um
i'm [ __ ] winded all the time here
i mean before i start in the special
like you'll notice about 30 minutes in
if i'm like
it's so embarrassing and i said it
before i said it again
i don't know how you guys do it but like
out you
feel good here right and people actually
yeah yeah
and then when you go down to street
level do you [ __ ] fight crime and
[ __ ] is that what you think
it's on a sea level you guys pick up
cars over your heads and you're like are
you a superhero
no i'm from denmark
[Applause]
right there winded winded raised my
voice
tired as [ __ ] dude okay
around downtown denver you guys have
some uh
you've got some [ __ ] you've got some
spoiled homeless people here
literally bought some food walked it out
to the dude he opened it and he goes i
don't eat that i go
i go what do you mean he goes what is
that hummus i go yeah and he goes i
don't eat that
[Laughter]
i'm like wanna he was like i don't like
the texture i'm like
you live in a box eat the [ __ ] hummus
this isn't the first bad decision you've
made i promise you
today i got asked a question that nobody
has ever asked me before
and it [ __ ] stumped me i was talking
to a friend of mine on the phone i was
interviewing him we were doing a little
interview from me
and i asked him a question i'm sure he's
been asked a million times he's a gay
guy and i asked him i said when did you
know you were gay
and he told me and then he asked me a
question nobody's ever asked me before
at the end of the interview he said to
me
when did you know you weren't gay and i
was like what
he goes what was the moment i was like
was there supposed to be a moment
so i started to think about it i'm like
was there a moment
and i think there was and i bet you it's
the same for most straight guys
the moment you realize you're not gay is
when you're a teenager
and you're masturbating and you get
you look down at the wrong time and you
get a little bit of your own [ __ ] on your
face you're like i don't [ __ ] like
that at all
you know that you know it's happened to
all of us one point in time
that hits your face you're like i'm not
on that team that's not my team i don't
like that [ __ ]
yeah you know it's funny i told my
brother i go yeah man
he goes yeah that happened to me twice
dude i go twice
yeah i knew i didn't like it enough the
first time where i was like that [ __ ] is
not happening to me again that means you
leaned into it the second time
so you guys uh uh
i'm i mean first of all i love love love
love love this club
and um i am
i'm super excited i have been waiting
i've been waiting to tell to try these
stories at this club
so you guys we're gonna hear just a
sweatshirt everybody um
we're gonna you guys wanna we're gonna
hear some jokes nobody's heard we're
ready for some new new stuff
okay okay so
you want queen city
[Music]
oh i had no idea why you said that
i was like what am i putting out there
that that's my nickname all of a sudden
it's weird when you take off your
sweatshirt and someone's like what's up
queen city
[Music]
i just want you to know uh nobody's that
surprised
i know you sound surprised i guess we
gotta leave
people think i'm loud
[Laughter]
might be a good idea
i think not [ __ ] one ounce of
self-awareness
i guess she thinks i'm being loud
jesus not the best way to [ __ ] please
your case i guess
all right well
that was fun
my daughter by the way and i will say
this with confidence a
ride or die chick she always has been
let me tell you so here's how i knew
right up front about her okay
so my youngest son jacob was about four
we're at one of those indoor playgrounds
and my daughter was probably seven there
was a ten-year-old boy picking on my son
and i was like oh i'm off to beat the
[ __ ] out of a ten-year-old today
and then my daughter walks up to him and
goes and he's up
this much taller she walks up and she
goes hey and he goes yeah
and she goes you see this and he goes
yeah and she goes
and he goes what was that for and she
goes you're going to see a lot more of
it if you don't stop messing with him
move along and i was like oh
[ __ ] yeah
my son ready for this so he's not super
bright
and um and uh
at my house cleaning out the trash is
one of my jobs
so i go into this room to empty the
trash can and there's 12 rubber wrappers
and rubbers in there
and i go yeah that's the look i had too
i was like that's a good week's work
right there
definitely a teenager my age i'm like
listen you can hold on to those other
eight because uh
doesn't happen so i
call him in i go hey man and he's like
yo
i go first of all i thought we were
going to talk before you had sex
and he goes no no no we are it's
something completely different and i was
like
i was like what he goes well if you must
know
i think i'm gonna have sex soon so i'm
just practicing putting them on and
taking them off
and i said dude why are you doing that
he goes dad i've never had sex before
i don't want it to take so long where i
give her a chance where she could change
her mind
[Music]
i was like you know what dude you're not
that stupid that's pretty smart actually
one time okay so he he his his
girlfriend he
were gonna get a little hot and heavy
and he wanted some
fatherly he wanted the fatherly talk and
he comes home super excited he's like
daddy dad okay hey oh
so you know ashley and i are going to be
alone together for the first time we're
going to be doing some things that i've
never done before
anyway so i was wondering if i could uh
if i could just ask you a couple
questions
uh but they might make you a little
uncomfortable
and i was like well don't you have a
friend or uh
i mean look if you're gonna die we
should talk but other than that i don't
need to know anything that's happened
and he was like dad i just i don't want
to embarrass myself in front of my
friends so can i ask you
i'm like all right and he goes okay so
he was another dad
we're going to be alone together you
know i like her a lot and
i don't want to embarrass myself and i
want her to still like me on saturday so
just give me the right answers okay and
i go okay dude he goes okay
so we're gonna be kissing and my eyes
are gonna be
closed right and i go yeah don't be
creepy open eye kissy guy
isn't that the worst when you're kissing
somebody and you just crack your eye but
they're like this
and you're like well [ __ ] tonight's
the night i die i guess
i don't know why you'd stare at me from
an inch and away you [ __ ] psycho okay
good
and he goes yeah i go yeah eyes closed
and he goes okay dad good
question number one answer
and he goes you know i know what to do
here and he told me he was a pro
he doesn't know how to undo a bra but
either did i leave in high school
so i was like well you know you figure
it out right
yeah i didn't tell them guys when i
wanted to see boobs in high school my
bra move was this
[Music]
and it cuts the titties in half and
you're like why are they so low
what's the deal
so he goes he goes you know i know what
to do here and i go you got that he goes
yeah okay
and he goes and then he goes and then
dad he starts to slowly walk his fingers
down his thumb and i'm like what the
[ __ ] is about to happen
and he goes and then dad he goes this
area here
and i i i'm just gonna quote it because
i don't think i could beat it with a
joke that i would write
he goes this area here
this is where i hear things get a little
tricky
and i said no yeah you're right that's
that's correct yep
[Music]
and he said you know that because if my
eyes are closed and the lights are out i
can't see anything
so like how how when you're doing it
like how do you
okay when you're like how would you
and he was like let me just start over
uh
kissing eyes closed boobs like them take
a walk down to tricky town here we are
and i was thinking i knew i should have
got high today like this is like
and he goes because dad like this you
know this like when you're doing it
like how what's your like what's your uh
what oh
this is this is getting awkward isn't it
and i said dude we are so far past
awkward
i'm on [ __ ] suicide watch when you
ask me the question
[ __ ] okay dad i'm gonna ask you here we
go
how like when your dad okay how okay
here we go
dad when you do it how do you touch a
woman's banana how do you do that and i
was like
you want to know how i took you
i can't tell you that i don't know
google it why are you asking me
[ __ ] it's on the internet for sure it's
on the internet
and i'm not giving you my secrets i
worked really hard for those secrets
not everything works in high school
right trial and error trial and error
trial and error some [ __ ] works some
[ __ ] doesn't you [ __ ] try something
else
look every man in america stumbled out
of the gates you think i'm gonna kick
you to the finish line
[ __ ] you figure it out like the rest of
us dude
[Applause]
put your time in son you don't go from
apprentice to sorcerer in one day that's
all i'm saying pretty sure it took harry
potter seven movies right
seven eight i don't [ __ ] know all i'm
saying is the first time i went down a
girl's pants
nobody told me although it would have
been nice the first time i went down a
girl's pants
nobody told me that the hole was so
far back i remember pushing around here
for like 20 minutes i'm like what's
the deal with this
is it is it gonna pop open or
no wonder they call it the clam i think
i'm hitting the shell right now like
do i need a wi-fi password for this one
little big little pig let me in like i
don't know what's happening
and then when i finally hit a hole i
thought i'm so far back
i'm in the wrong one for sure
i slipped over the vagina and teenage
boys are the worst at sex
because when i finally realized i was in
the right place
i just left my finger there like i was
taking her temperature or something
no movement or anything just this the
whole time
like she was a thanksgiving turkey and i
was just waiting
[Applause]
i think i even leaned in and was like
does that feel good baby
now i'll tell you something else you
know when my son was growing up i did
not when he was learning how to ride a
bike i did not allow him to wear elbow
pads or knee pads
i did not guys listen the biggest
mistake you can make with your kid is to
protect them from anything bad happening
to them
until they're 18. that's why we have
these giant [ __ ] babies walking
around the streets
because we haven't allowed the kids to
overcome obstacles
look i want my son to know when he's
when he jumps and
falls off a bike if he scrapes his knee
all he has to do is go like this
get back on the [ __ ] bike
now look look i made him wear a helmet
that
that i wouldn't you know that's a tough
lesson to learn yeah
[Applause]
you don't want him at the family reunion
like dad said it would make me tough
like you don't want that
hey can i have some more cream cans
please yeah that's
butt elbow pads and knee pads yeah and i
know some people called me a bad parent
am i the bad parent
or or am i look if the first time my son
scraped his knee was when he was 18
years old
and he's running across a college campus
trying to find a call like a girl and
he's like
[Applause]
oh my god what is that pain i don't know
what that is
yeah yeah he's gonna start wearing knee
pads but for a different reason
you heard me you heard me
now look look all day look we all
are getting older lagging i will tell
you like
okay okay
you know we know i did notice a little
part
of my body this is like the thing that i
noticed
the first thing i noticed i was getting
a little older okay
okay
okay my wife's here so it's okay tell us
um okay
so we're all
we're all familiar with the term come
shot right
yeah as you get older it's not as much
of a shot you know what i mean
it's like a slow uh like a slow drip do
you know what i mean like
it used to come out like this
[Laughter]
and now it just kind of goes
right i mean i could give you a facial
but it's going to be like this
that seems aggressive i would never do
that to somebody
that seems aggressive
i grew up poor and my dad was also
pretty cheap and because of that we me i
missed out on a lot of experiences and i
grew up
man i'm i'm bummed that i did this but i
grew up through my 20s and 30s
like if i saw a steak on the menu that
was 24.00
and i saw a chicken that was 17 i'd be
like i should get the chicken even
though i wanted the steak
do you know what i mean like i [ __ ]
hate that my dad put that in my head
so what i've started to do is listen
guys it's important not to be
willy-nilly with your [ __ ] money
but if you got 100 bucks and it's
between 700 bucks and going to a concert
you've always wanted to see go to that
[ __ ] concert
here's the deal a year from now you're
not gonna have any idea where that
hundred dollars went but you'll remember
the concert so make some [ __ ]
memories while you can still make some
memories all right
so uh taking that into account last
september i got to see six bands in one
weekend all on the bucket list now
i spent more than i should have on this
concert it was it was a
it was old cello it was coachella for
old people did anybody go
did you know what i'm talking about it
was the stones the who mccartney neil
young roger waters
and bob dylan all the same weekend it
was amazing has anyone in here ever seen
bob dylan before
yeah he eats a bag of dicks that
[ __ ] he's so bad
did he play any hits when you saw no
what [ __ ] hit
dude doesn't play one hit are you
kidding me and
i was so mad i'm like play tango with
the blue and the guy next to me was like
yeah well it's bob dylan he's earned the
right to play what he wants and i would
agree with you
if he's playing in his own [ __ ]
living room but he wasn't
there were 90 000 people there who paid
a lot of [ __ ] money
paint tangles up in blue you piece of
beef jerky [ __ ] you
i will fight bob dylan right now i'll
tell you that right now i'll fight that
[ __ ] i think i got a shot at bob
dylan i'd like to hit him once just to
hear him go
i just
just a quick
but on the way in right i told my
brothers i'm like hey guys
i'm taking mushrooms this weekend
and they were like which night i said
did you hear me this weekend
and they were like why are you gonna
they go you you're gonna do that by
yourself and i said
no there's gonna be 90 000 people there
and they were like you're not but you
don't know any of them i was like well
i'm gonna
now okay so and by the way i did it out
of respect for the bands we were going
to see i felt like they would want me to
be [ __ ] up right
so a [ __ ] got a curiosity round of
applause
and i'm assuming this will be a larger
round of applause and in most cities
people who have taken mushrooms before
okay guys i was in huntsville alabama
last weekend i asked that question
and one dude goes i got some on my salad
right now
[Laughter]
and not what i'm talking about uh
so after dylan i was like i'm taking the
mushrooms now
i'm not i'm not i'm not putting myself
through another disappointing show
now at following dylan was the stones
and i've never seen the stones before
and so uh and by the way sitting
next to me was this old hispanic couple
and the dude had those like the round
tiny glasses and he had a tiny ponytail
you know one of these
and it was pulled tight so dude looks
surprised the whole show like
so and she scratched his back
the entire concert
two and a half hours
[Music]
so about five minutes before the music
starts i get my first little warm hug
and i'm like
i'm like this is about to be the best
night of my [ __ ] life right
and so the guy next to me he turns to me
he goes hey man
and i go hey and he goes what's your
name
i said josh and he said who do you think
the best rock band of all time is josh
and listen guys i'm about to trip balls
right
[Music]
so the last thing i want to do is have a
conversation with the mexican john
lennon do you know what i mean like
i'm on pasadena on that right [ __ ]
now right
so i just tell him what i think is going
to answer the
stop most conversation i said the
beatles and he goes whoa man
it's the stones she and i have seen the
stones 66 times
and she said yeah and we re fall in love
every
show and i was like yeah i was like
you're not sweet
and i said that's gonna be very cool for
me to watch the stones for the first
time
next to people who've seen them 66 times
and i'm gonna watch them re-fall in love
right in front of my face that's about
to melt off my [ __ ] skull
you know what i mean
[Music]
i felt like telling them i hope you
don't mind watching this concert next to
the ghost rider because
[Music]
i'm not for sure what's going to happen
from here on out you know
so i and then
start in and i'm like oh my god
right i couldn't believe what was
happening
not kidding 10 minutes in dude turns to
me and he goes
hey man and i go ahead and he goes
what's your name and i was like
i said josh
and he goes who do you think the best
rock and roll band of all time is josh
and for a second i thought oh my god
these mushrooms are amazing
i was like this is the most visceral
deja vu i've ever had in my entire life
and honestly i'm gonna tell you i'm not
gonna lie to you for a second i thought
i could see the [ __ ] future
like i know how this conversation ends
oh i'm going to see this concert twice
[ __ ] yeah
but we did the whole thing 66 times we
fall in love
not kidding no joke 12 minutes later
dude turns to me and he goes hey man
and i go don't you ask me that [ __ ]
question again dude
and his wife goes to me you'll have to
excuse him
[Music]
he's done a lot of drugs he doesn't have
any short-term memory and i was like
well no wonder you got to see the stone
66 [ __ ] times
and just so you know you don't re fall
in love he thinks he bangs some chick at
the stones concert every weekend like
[Music]
not as romantic as you think it is man
i'm just saying
and then i will tell you what the true
privilege of my life being there that
weekend was watching a generation of
people
watch their idols for the last time guys
so cool to see
so cool to see because they were
partying without inhibition look if we
saw
a bar full of 65 year old people
upstairs getting [ __ ] up you'd be like
go
home
yeah you'd make a group decision you're
like hey all of you
you need to go
right but this concert was for them it
was for them to come and relive a
snapshot of their life
so they partied without inhibition and
it was amazing to see and because of
that
there was a lot of old white guy dance
circles popping up all over the place
if you haven't seen one of those
and when i say dance circle there was a
lot of two gun salutes you know
and you could tell when they liked the
song you know why the guns went up in
the air
right
there was one guy near me doing a lot of
the pencil
and then near me also there was a big
guy doing kicks like this
he had to go like 240 big dude he's
kicking he's like yeah
and i was like look at the big guy go
like he's killing it
and then big guy just collapses
and i was like oh no
he [ __ ] river danced himself to death
like
and he's not moving and i'm like oh this
dude is in [ __ ] trouble
right so they put it they come in emts
come they put them on a stretcher
wheel him out you know and he's saying
his eyes are closed and one of his
friends is near me leans over and goes
the dude has to be like mid-60s or
something anything's over he goes hey
man
you're gonna be okay
and the guy just opens his eyes and he
goes
yeah i'm just really tired
and his friend said what he goes yeah i
got tired from dancing around so i laid
down on the ground
and then the emt said yeah i can't lay
here and i told him i'm not [ __ ]
getting up i'm too tired
and the emt said if you don't get up sir
we're gonna have to wheel you out of
here and i said that actually sounds
kind of
rock and nice and this is when [ __ ] got
a little weird
there was about a 280 290 pound dude
running around shirtless doing this to
people
and i'm watching him and i'm like
boy i really hope he doesn't come over
here you know like
so he comes over and his belly's all
sweaty so there's like tracers
flying off his stomach and his whole
stomach's moving all at once and i'm
like
i'm never looking away i knew i was
gonna get [ __ ] trapped in that thing
right
and then he said something to me that i
promise you
has never been uttered before in the
history of human
beings he shakes his belly at me and he
looks at me and he goes hey
i go what's up he goes how many knuckles
deep do you think he can go on my belly
button i go
what he goes how many knuckles deep i go
none
none knuckles deep dude zero knuckles
deep and he goes why not i was like wow
why would i
and he goes everybody's doing it i go
who the [ __ ] is doing that
and he goes everybody now look guys i'm
shrooming
you know what i mean and i don't want to
be the only guy who doesn't figure [ __ ]
this dude's belly button you know what i
mean
i don't want to be debbie downer you
know what i mean i want to be part of
the group
so i go to him i go uh
oh what finger should i use
and he goes he goes i'd use the index i
go okay
guys wait it gets so much worse
so
i go to lube up my finger
and he goes nah you won't need lube and
i was like
[Music]
oh that's good news for me
and it just [ __ ]
with room to spare right and i look at
him i go we got room to spare big fella
and he goes okay
and i go to pull my finger out and you
know when you put your finger in one of
those chinese finger locks
and for whatever reason when you try to
pull it out it clamps down on it
i couldn't get my finger out of his
[ __ ] belly button i went
full palm on this dude's stomach like
yeah
because there's no way i'm going out
like that right i'm like
and it just popped out right as soon as
it pops out he looks at me and he goes
we finally found somebody to do it
i said i thought everybody was doing
that he goes who would do that i go
[Applause]
now let's get into a little truth time
you ready for a little truth time
truth truth time as a man as a man
as a man i had to fight every fiber in
my body not to smell that finger one
[ __ ] time don't yuck me you
hypocritical [ __ ]
you raise your nuts the first thing you
do is smell them you got a unicorn on
your finger you're never gonna smell
that [ __ ] again
now listen i did it i didn't i didn't
i didn't i did not do it i did not do it
i did it and then i gave my brother a
dirty sanchez and i was like hey dude
what does that smell like he walked
around the whole day like this
[Music]
because that's the type of [ __ ] now
somebody asked me to tell this story so
i certainly will
um uh i have a favorite practical joke
um i love practical jokes they're like
my favorite thing to do to people
um i like being the recipient too like a
good practical joke i'm on board for
that [ __ ] too
uh and my kids know that i scare easy by
the way i scare my kids and pull
practical jokes on them
i want you to know that i i scare easy
i'm a jazz hander
my daughter has more videos of me doing
this [ __ ] you
[Music]
because my hat always follows with the
[ __ ] you
cause i try to get a little more manly
after my [ __ ] you
so i love practical jokes this is my
best one ever
my buddy asked me to throw him a a a a
bachelor party and i was like man you
don't want me to do that
i said i'm a comedian i always go for
the laugh and then i hope we can shake
hands and be
friends later but i'm gonna [ __ ] up your
day
and he was like i don't think you'll do
that i said i don't think you're
listening
i'm already trying to decide how to [ __ ]
with you so
[Music]
can we just like uh not have me do it
he was like buddy you've been to vegas
more than any of us you plan the party
you get the girl
now look i got him a girl for the end of
his party that's what he wanted a
stripper
i'm not a stripper guy i never have been
a stripper guy i don't really care
but he wanted a stripper at the end of
his party that's cool i
wanted the beginning of the party to be
for me
and what did i want to watch what do i
like way more than strippers
i like weird [ __ ] guys if you're like
hey man
this is about to be some weird [ __ ]
happening ally i'll be like i'm gonna
[ __ ] watch
that
100 i love it how weird i wanted people
walking out of his party
like this what the [ __ ] just happened in
there
like was some guy walking out with a
limp like why are my hands dirty like
weird [ __ ] right
where did i think i could find that i
went on craigslist in vegas
oh guys i have never felt so horny and
sad at the same time in my entire life
scrolling through scrolling through it's
all sex stuff i don't want that i want
weird
and then weird jumped off the screen of
me this woman's advertisement was
three words that's it and those three
words were
i'll wrestle ya and i was like [ __ ] yeah
you will
that at least deserves a phone call i
think right
i call her on the phone she is six foot
250.
and her special skill is that she'll
come over to your house
she'll get naked and she'll toss you
around for a little while
and i was like well what time can you
get here
[Music]
so she shows up and i open the door and
she's legitimate six foot 250 right
and she's holding a foot long sub and 24
buffalo wings
not kidding and she waves them in my
face and she goes
you got a room where i could go fuel up
before the match and i was like
first of all [ __ ] yes i do right in
there
and i said second of all you should know
that the person you're wrestling today
doesn't know there's going to be a match
[Music]
you know i don't know if that changes
your professional approach at all
[Music]
so she goes off into her room my buddy
comes over
and we've got him on a stool just like
this one and
my other friends are standing behind him
when we get him blindfolded
and he's well i don't want to ruin the
surprise you know
and he's like oh this chair is one ralph
you made away from an accident i'll tell
you that
right now oh
you don't think he knows he's 900 pounds
he [ __ ] knows
look at this so um
he's sitting there and he's like
i'm so excited and i was like
me too
[Music]
and he says i'm ready and i said okay
and i call her out
now none of my other friends knew what i
had planned
so when she walked out of that room
naked
collectively they were like what the
[ __ ]
and as she got closer i saw she still
had buffalo wing sauce around or not
i was gonna get her napkin but i was
like i'm sorry that [ __ ] is too funny on
your face i am
so sorry so she stands in front of him
six foot 250.
oh i forgot to tell you the best part my
buddy five eight
and 140 and like a like a like a hoo
like a soft 140 right
so the size difference alone like i
don't know what's gonna happen but i'm
pretty sure i'm gonna [ __ ] like it
[Music]
and he says i'm ready and i said okay
and i take off his blindfold
and the only word
he could get out of his mouth before she
ripped him out of his chair
[Music]
was why
right
and she lifted him up like this his
little feet were dangling in the air
she started tossing around the room like
a rag doll and we were all like
guys she would jump on top of him and he
had to push her fat out of his face to
talk to us
he would be like tell her to stop how
long she gonna be here
i can't breathe why does she smell like
buffalo wings
right
[Music]
there was one time when she was
straddling him like this
beating him in the face with her titties
just
[Music]
i don't think you're getting the right
visual okay uh
guys this isn't five foot two 110 pounds
this is six foot 250
just
titties that's how big her titties were
they made that noise through the air
it was like being hit with a tint
missile just
dude had a swollen eye from titty
punches you've never seen that in the
history of [ __ ] never ever i'll tell
you that right now
so she thinks her job is done right she
walks over here to this side of the room
my buddy gets up mad you know when you
can tell someone is mad
where they never take their eyes off of
that thing they're mad at
so he gets up and he walks away from her
like this
[Music]
and then something in him just snapped
and he just looks at her and he goes
i'm gonna [ __ ] you up
[Music]
and like a wave of calm crashed over her
like serious like bruce lee
entered the dragon com she was just like
and they ran at each other guys you
understand what's happening
they're [ __ ] fighting for real now
it's the best gift i've ever given to
myself ever are you kidding me
they're running at each other i'm like i
don't even know how this is gonna end oh
my gosh
they're running at each other and my
buddy was mad and he screamed i wanna
take you down
running at each other full speed and he
ran into her i'm gonna tell you
something he really did try to take her
down i'll tell you what
he did not
all i can tell you is that when his
little body hit hers
she kind of absorbed him for a second
and he disappeared i was like where the
[ __ ] did he go
and then she just shot him out across
the room
boom and he slid on the floor and one of
my friends ran up to him and went that
just [ __ ] happened to you
[Music]
and she was mad that he challenged her
or something so she goes to us
you want to see my finishing move you
want me to finish them and i grew up
with hulk hogan and randy the macho man
savage so i was like
[Music]
i didn't know if she was coming out the
top rope or dropping a leg or whatever i
wanted to see that [ __ ] right
so she starts to run to him and she was
like finish him and we go yeah
she goes finishing moving we go yeah and
she goes you want to see the finishing
move and we go yeah and then she
sat on his head and we went
not that finishing move [ __ ] guys his
little head disappeared
all you could see were his tiny arms
slapping her back like
oh it was a fight for life i'm telling
you that right now
it was the weirdest [ __ ] i've ever seen
it was like a reverse birth it was
[ __ ] up
and here's how you know you pulled a
good practical joke
a good practical joke is a joke that
continues to pay dividends
long after the joke is over
so like a month and a half after the
wedding after the uh party two weeks
before the wedding
i ran into his dad
and his dad goes uh hey you're not
coming to the wedding i was uninvited to
the wedding by the way
totally worth it totally worth it you
guys want to see how he uninvited me
this is my favorite part this is how
we're going to find him
she just got off of him and he stands up
and he goes
you're not coming to the wedding
so here's how his dad goes you know come
with a wedding i'm going now
and he knows why not and i said oh uh
tim didn't tell you and he said no
and i go huh do you got a couple minutes
sit down
and then his dad used that story
as his best man speeches and what
[ __ ] winner winner
[Music]
all right let's take a couple tunes and
get out of here
all right so i'm not a good guitar
player everybody should know that right
up front
i play i play twice a week for seven
minutes at a time
and um
lion king
it's the weirdest guitar request of all
time
lion i wonder who leaves lion king he's
like i gotta learn that [ __ ] on guitar
for sure
lion king
you good dude are you good
you you good i know i know he did i i've
been looking
i've had 9-1 dialed on my phone for the
last [ __ ] 30 minutes
just ready to press that last one for
you at any time there was one point in
time where i was like i don't even know
what the [ __ ] he's looking at
did you yeah
are you with him too yeah no this i love
this guy but chris you
there were a couple times dude right
where i was like oh he's not paying it
he's
like if i'm here you'd be like this
and then out of nowhere you'd be like
and i was like
i don't know what show he's watching but
it seems fun
[Music]
come on board brother i've been right
there
that's why i'm asking you good he's good
all right
yeah what's your name man josh
all right man yeah
josh uh what's that yeah this song is
for you
uh it's not uh
i wrote the song after i talked to this
girl i went to high school with
and i remembered when we were in high
school we had decided we were going to
be each other's firsts
because we were the last two virgins
that we knew
and i remember when we were in high
school i called her i was like you know
what
we should be each others first like
because we went to preschool together
so i've known you forever like you can't
do anything to embarrass yourself in
front of me
i can't embarrass myself in front of you
let's be each other's first and she said
you know what that's a great idea
we're gonna be each other's first this
is gonna be a magical night
and this song is how that night went
said i'd be your first and you'd be
mine we'd be together
until the end of time
i laid her down and i kissed her lips
jeans on jeans and hips on
hips well things were going
just as we planned she was my girl and i
was her man yeah
right before we began willing
came in my pants
came right in my pants but please don't
tell my friends that i
came in my pants and she was good to me
said it could happen to anyone
she said she'd give it a second try
she called the first one a dry run
[Music]
i set the mood just right
and to make sure what happened last
night didn't happen again
i jerked off four times before she came
over
and then i jerked up two more times
because i was a teenager
and i could do that back then and it
[ __ ] felt great
i wish there were more guys in here
because they would get that
[Music]
and she looks so pretty
she unbuttoned my jeans no mess
hello kitty
yeah and then my hand brushed her titty
and i came on her pants
i came under lime green pants
what the [ __ ] is going on i'll never see
a vagina
at this rate yeah years went by
[Music]
and we talked from time to time
i met her husband at the reunion
i really liked him he was a nice guy
[Music]
he and i were about eight drinks in
don't get ahead of me now don't get out
of me don't get out of me
when he smiled and he said
you know man i gotta tell you and he
said with a grin
i know you came in your pants and now
you
came on her pants too you know she
tells all her friends the guy
on tv came in his pants she started
a facebook page and it's called
sticky drawers where you can tell funny
stories about sex
oh and believe me she's told yours
i wanted revenge i didn't know what to
do
we all got drunk and ended up in my room
they passed out first
[Music]
that's a rookie move
so i
came on her face and then i
came on his pants to put that on your
facebook page
with a big old [ __ ] you
[Music]
all right so i wrote this song this is
the first weekend i'm doing it without
my notebook so i hope i remember it
i'm not a good guitar player i wrote
this um
uh song around valentine's day because
my wife is just so good at buying
[ __ ] gifts
but i always tell her you think too hard
about it gifts for guys
super easy you don't have to think so
hard father's day
valentine's day birthday doesn't matter
and so this song is she's actually right
here tonight so
this song you want to bring her out
you're always so thoughtful and
gifts on my special day
asking friends and family about things
that make me
feel great but let me
try to help you let me
ease your mind
i just want a [ __ ] and a sandwich
[Music]
let me save you some time i want a
[ __ ]
and a sandwich i don't need another
[ __ ] tie
and i haven't worn cologne since the 8th
grade
you and your sister use the couple's
massage
i want a [ __ ] and a sandwich
at the same time
at the same time
at the same time tiny tiny tiny tiny
tiny tiny time
[Music]
i like turkey on wheat
i like ham on ride
but to make this day complete well
there's one more thing that i'd like to
try
now i know when guys say try
women always think that we're talking
about anal
[Music]
and that's true
[Music]
but not this time
i just like a [ __ ] and a sandwich
[Music]
while i'm watching tv
turn on espn and little march madness
watching men dribble balls up and down
the court
[Music]
now i know on your special day i'll give
you anything
that you need trips jewelry or
clothing i'd bring the moon down
to its knees
you don't have to tell me i know
what you really want
[Music]
you want me naked you're washing dishes
and a ryan gosling mess
throwing votes in the rain
telling all of your friends
quotes from the notebook over again
i wrote her every single day
[Music]
what end of what guns and roses song is
that patience right
[Music]
let's see if we get the voice tonight
for this
[Music]
[Applause]
while i watch tv man i promise not to
get
any crumbs on your head i just wanna
blow job
while i watch some tv that'll feel so
fine to me in a [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
who is
guys i gotta go thank you very much for
coming out tonight we'll see you next
time
[Applause]
josh lewis everybody come on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
you